what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime Eilperin today I will be
explaining and analyzing the very latest
game-changing events in the black clover
story including the rage of Austin's
demon Dante's secret master plan and the
long awaited introduction of what might
be the mysterious and elusive
vice-captain of the black bull squad way
back in January of 2017 yuki Tabata
confirmed in an interview that the black
bulls do have a vice captain but he or
she has not been introduced yet and now
we are seemingly finally about to meet
the vice captain and let me just say
that the magic that this presumptive
vice captain possesses is unbelievable
we honestly got some really impactful
reveals in a very short period of time
reveals that are going to shape the rest
of this incredible war arc for many
chapters to come we have so much to talk
about things are really getting crazy
and I mean that in the best way possible
so let's get into it if you enjoy the
black over content over here on anime
uproar please leave a like to let me
know it really does help and if you
happen to be new to the channel or you
just haven't subscribed yet please
consider subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you might not know this
but in order to get notified by YouTube
you have to go through the trouble of
subscribing clicking the bell and then
selecting the option that says all if
you don't go through those steps you're
gonna miss a lot of our videos and
YouTube is gonna recommend like CNN and
fox news to you instead of our content
it sucks it makes no sense but that's
how YouTube works in 2020 you can also
hit me up on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar finally this video will of
course contain black color manga
spoilers as opposed to some other shows
like MHA or Demon Slayer the manga of
black clover is not that much ahead of
the anime however it is still a bit
ahead so please proceed with caution you
have been warned the latest chapter
starts off with kostas demon absolutely
furious and shouting stuff like I'll
kill you and I'll slaughter you all of
this is happening inside of a siscon
justice and hasta himself seems
genuinely shocked and taken aback by the
demon's reaction something has really
angered the demon inside of Asta's
grimoire and the anger appears to be a
direct result of austin's recent defeat
at the hands of Dante and his demon
Lucifer the big question is what was it
that made Asta's demon so angry so
quickly is it just regular demon rivalry
maybe Austin's demon just doesn't like
to lose and especially not to another
demon so he was absolutely infuriated
that he and hasta fell short in their
battle against Dante I mean it's
possible but there might be something
else going on here something more
personal from the conversation that we
saw Dante have with Lucifer it seems
pretty clear that Lucifer does not
recognize Austin's demon he doesn't know
who this demon is and he assumes that it
has to be a lower ranked demon whose
power cannot compare to the power of
high ranked demons like those who are
possessing the dark triad but could it
be that even though Lucifer apparently
doesn't recognize hostes demon Austin's
demon does recognize Lucifer is it
possible that at some point in the past
perhaps back inside the demon world
itself Lucifer did something to Austin's
demon Anastas demon now wants revenge or
could it be the Rastas demon is just
sick of being looked down upon as a
lower ranked demon by his fellow demons
and so he is anxious to prove them wrong
by defeating them in battle Paquin's ugh
red was defeated austin's demon seemed
almost giddy and even taunted Zagg red
zag red was his senior his senpai and
yet segrete fell at the hands of Oz's
demon although that battle was
definitely a team effort since demons
and the demon world have had such a
major focus in this story at this point
it is definitely not out of the realm of
possibility that osdas demon might have
some personal grudge against Lucifer and
these other higher ranked demons and it
is likely that during this demon focused
arc we are finally going to get some
more information about osdas demon and
how he ended up possessing osdas
grimoire in the first place I have been
extremely curious about Asta's demon for
a very long time
I can't wait to learn more about him
including his real name and his origin
story and I really hope that this arc
will provide the answers that we
desperately need back in the world
outside of Austen's head Oster regains
consciousness but he realizes that he
cannot move his body
astha remembers the terrible wound that
gauche had suffered that was the thing
that set him off in the first place and
hasta uses his ability to sense key in
order to determine whether gauche is
still alive as we know gauche is in fact
still alive thanks to grey and hasta is
relieved to confirm that this is indeed
the case the chapter then shifts focus
back to the fight between Dante and Yami
as you recall the previous chapter ended
with Yami landing an epic slash right
across Dante's abdomen Yami had
condensed his mana zone in order to make
his mana thicker and then he channeled
that thick dark magic mana into an epic
sword attack called dark cloak di slash
an attack that never misses and it is
true that the attack didn't miss but
unfortunately for Yami Dante is not done
yet I mean I think that we all saw that
coming an epic battle like this isn't
gonna end so soon and Dante begins to
laugh like an absolute maniac as he
opens his grimoire in the next moment
Dante begins to use a completely
different type of magic from the gravity
magic that he has been using thus far
this magic allows Dante to manipulate
the flesh on his abdomen until the
entire wound is healed within seconds
this is especially significant because
the injury was caused by a combination
of a blade and dark magic but Dante is
still able to almost instantly heal
himself and if you're thinking that
maybe this is some kind of weird use of
gravity magic in order to control his
own flesh Vanessa actually confirms that
this healing magic appears to be a
completely different magic attribute
from the gravity magic that Dante had
been using up to this point both lanessa
and Yami are confused as to how Dante is
able to use two completely different
magic attributes it seems to me that
there are several possible explanations
for why Dante
is able to do this the first is that
Dante had his own magic attribute before
he was possessed by the demon Lucifer
and of course Lucifer has his own
demonic magic attribute so as a result
of being possessed by Lucifer Dante can
use both the demons magic attribute and
his own magic attribute since this
healing spell looked quite demonic to me
and it actually reminded me of some of
the Reds magic I would assume that
gravity magic is Dante's original magic
attribute and that this healing spell
came from the demon himself now that
isn't to say that Dante's gravity magic
wasn't affected by Lucifer I think that
Dante's original magic has become much
stronger thanks to the demon but it is
likely that on top of strengthening
Dante's original magic Lucifer also has
a unique magic attribute of his own that
Dante now has access to hasta of course
doesn't have the luxury of using
multiple magic attributes because he
himself was born with no magic so the
only magic attribute that he can use is
the anti magic that comes from his demon
however assuming that members of the
dark triad were all born with some type
of magic it is likely that all three of
them have access to at least two magic
attributes their original attribute and
a secondary attribute that they have
acquired from their respective demons
however even though I believe this to be
the most likely explanation we have to
remember that alternative possibilities
have already been established in the
black clover story including of course
Mars's ability to use both crystal magic
and fire magic because the demon kingdom
was able to artificially fuse two
grimoires together in order to create
one grimoire with two separate magic
attributes dante situation does not
appear to be a case of an artificially
fused grimoire but I still think that we
have to at least mention that
possibility at this point Dante goes
from a dignified man of culture to a
full-blown psycho he starts praising
Yami for making him feel any wrath and
hate since those are the exact things
that excite him and make him feel alive
as we know he thrives on mal
and evil intent we learned that earlier
in his life
Dante was incredibly bored and nothing
satisfied his malice he killed people
and animals burned entire castles to the
ground and yet he always felt bored and
unsatisfied yeah this is definitely not
a huge red flag for a total and complete
psychopath Dante also didn't have any
facial hair earlier on in his life so he
basically looked like a generic
protagonist from a high-school anime
with the additional quality of being a
depraved lunatic of course as Dante
talks excitedly about Yami being the one
who will open up a more magnificent
world Yami is just creeped out by Dante
and he calls him a psycho with a hipster
beard which is pretty accurate not gonna
lie Dante's got like this carefully
trimmed Van Dyke beard thing going on
meanwhile Yami just has good
old-fashioned manly scruff Yami is
highly skeptical about all this talk
coming from Dante about Yami being some
sort of magical key to another world but
Dante goes on to explain that using
Yami's dark magic and Williams world
tree magic he can open up a magic
channel called the tree of cliff fall
not really sure if that's the right
pronunciation but let's go with it
if this magic channel is activated this
world will become linked to the
underworld and this means that an army
of demons will be able to pour into this
world freely and turn this world into a
place that is absolutely overflowing
with malice this would presumably ensure
that Dante is a lot less bored in the
future in the panel where Dante
announces this we can see that the
demons apparently come in all sorts of
shapes and sizes there seem to be demons
with more than two eyes demons who look
like giant worms and so on all the black
balls are extremely freaked out when
they hear all this and Yami concludes
that Dante's plan is too dangerous to be
tolerated Yami decides that he must stop
Dante right here and now he cannot risk
allowing Dante to get away and turn his
insane plan into reality not only does
the plan require Dante to capture
William and of course
Yami himself but if more demons are
allowed to enter this world the dark
triad will be just the beginning of the
world's problems even on their own the
dark triad are already a massive danger
to the entire world we still haven't
even seen Vanek ax and Maggie Cole in
action but both Dante and Zenon have
already demonstrated that they are
incredibly dangerous and that their
magic is extremely deadly I'll be honest
when I first saw the words tree of cliff
auth I thought that this was just like a
word that Tabata invented for the
purposes of black clover this tree as
shown in the chapter looks a lot like
the Sephiroth tree and the Sephiroth
tree or the tree of life was already
referenced in black clover with the
elves and the apostles of Saphira so I
kind of just assumed that this was
another allusion to the same thing
however when I actually looked up the
tree of cliff auth I realized that this
was a separate concept in the Kabbalah
which is a specific school of thought
within Jewish mysticism the cliff
thought are the representation of evil
or impure spiritual forces and they are
considered to be the polar opposite of
the Sephiroth the cliff path represents
spiritual obstacles to holiness and
purity they are metaphorical shells
which conceal holiness and are
synonymous with impurity they are also
directly connected to the other side the
realm of evil so it is clear that this
tree of cliff thought that Dante
mentions is directly connected to the
cliff off in the Kabbalah and it appears
that this tree is the direct opposite of
the Tree of Life that the apostles of
sefar are used to open the shadow Palace
which as we know is a magical space
located between the realm of the living
and the underworld it seems that just
like the Tree of Life allows the elves
to open a magical space between worlds
so to the tree of cliff off this tree of
death is able to open a magical portal
between worlds and Dante wants to use
this portal to allow countless demons to
enter this world in order to create
absolute chaos this is a very
interesting concept we have the
Sephiroth and the cliff off the Tree of
Life and the tree of death
light and darkness
elves and demons and the fact that Dante
is planning to open a portal between the
human world and the demon world might
mean that we are going to have a demon
world arc sometime in the future which
is a prospect that I find absolutely
fascinating in all likelihood we're
going to meet new demons we're going to
explore new worlds we're going to learn
more about Austin's demon and it all
sounds extremely cool to me and I really
look forward to it after all of this the
chapter quickly shifts to a completely
different location
it takes us deep inside the snowy spade
Kingdom and we are taken inside a
massive castle which is presumably
located inside the spade Kingdom capital
we see two dark disciples strolling
through the castle and talking about how
bored they are apparently all of these
guys are extremely bored if they're not
like torturing or murdering someone one
of the men says that there have been
some rumors recently about a clover
Kingdom spy who managed to infiltrate
the Spade Kingdom but the other man
dismisses the rumor saying that any such
spy mission would be a disaster for the
spy so nonetheless the chapter then
jumps to Dante's private quarters where
a mysterious hooded figure is going
through Dante's personal papers the
notes that the hooded figure is looking
at appear to show the tree of cliff off
and presumably these notes are detailing
Dante's plans for opening the portal
between this world and the demon world
suddenly a spade kingdom official enters
the room and demands to know what the
hooded figure is doing there the
official quickly concludes that this
must be the infamous spy and he prepares
to destroy the spy with his magic Cobra
thingy but the spy just suddenly
disappears into the shadows beneath his
own feet and moments later this same
person emerges from the spate officials
own shadow grabs him and pulls him into
the darkness below until there is no
trace left of either person it is as if
both men were never even there the next
panel shows the same hooded figure
emerging from the shadows and yet again
and as he or she walks through the
castle
we see the symbol of the black Bulls
emerge from beneath the hooded figures
flowing robes and that is how this
incredible chapter ends with a number of
massive reveals that are about to change
the game in black clover and completely
shift the focus of this entire war arc
we just saw the unprecedented rage of
Austin's demon and it is safe to assume
that we are going to learn more about
the anti magic demon and his backstory
sometime soon
we also witness Dante revealing his
master plan to Yami a plan that includes
using dark magic and world tree magic to
open a portal between this world and the
demon world finally we learned that an
as-of-yet
unknown member of the black bulls has
been on a secret mission to infiltrate
the spade Kingdom as a spy this unknown
member has some pretty incredible shadow
based magic which allows him or her to
travel through shadows and to make
others disappear without a trace
within those same shadows earlier on in
the story Yami said that there were more
members of the black Bulls out there but
some of them were out on missions and
that is why they're never around this
appears to be one of those members and
if we take into consideration tabata
statement about a black bull
vice-captain already being out there
somewhere and if we also take into
consideration this mages incredible
shadow magic I think it's pretty safe to
assume that this black bull spy inside
the spade Kingdom is indeed the missing
black bulls vice-captain since the black
bull spy was wearing a cloak it is
impossible to tell what they look like
or whether the person is a man or woman
way back in Chapter two of black clover
we saw a bunch of silhouettes of the
black bull members and one long-haired
silhouette in particular appears to be a
member that we haven't met yet
could this be the spy inside the spade
Kingdom and the missing vice captain of
the black bull squad oh man I honestly
can't wait to find out my curiosity has
been piqued after that brief scene
inside the Spade Kingdom Castle and I am
really looking forward to the official
introduction of
this mysterious by and their incredible
shadow magic this really was a crucial
chapter that set the stage for future
developments in the story the pieces are
falling into place and the epic battle
between the dark triad and the clover
and hard kingdoms is heating up in a big
way I assume that the next step will be
to see what's going on in the battle
against Vanek I'm Maggie Kula and then
eventually everything will come together
in a final epic showdown a showdown that
will feature all three members of the
dark triad the black bull spy and a lot
more let me know what you guys think is
the spy inside the spade Kingdom the
missing vice captain of the black poles
also why was Austin's demon so
infuriated and what do you think about
Dante's master plan could we be heading
for a demon world arc at some point in
the future please share your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video you want to see more
black lower content right here on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know it really does help and if you have
to be new to anime uproar or you just
haven't subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also follow me on
twitter or instagram at anime uproar i
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for supporting
our work and making these videos
possible special thank you to baby r a
disciple of Lord we go himself another
big thank you to all of our the one-tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including in grata alone
Adam the world stealers the school bus
Tyson Kirino acquired respect and Pat a
heffa and I can't forget our pro hero to
your patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell drous Anatoly Cassatt's key on
hell Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor
cricket XP Ted no Ted Colter chose
Stanton very Gucci Alicia doctor
anomalous 69
Jessica Kayla fond Emperor otaku JCCC
waka
and the coach if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value for
you please consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]